perfect timing we've got the lastly I
want to mention now which is that all of
what we've done so far it kind of relied
on this step do you remember that step
how do we do it what results we take you
find your is that it's the difference of
cubes difference of cubes and just kind
of conveniently we've just been dealing
with cube roots a lot right the cube
roots then what game is this which is
what gave us this and that's how we go
difference of cubes okay
now you kind of got a problem because
you know what difference of squares are
yes
you know what difference of cubes are
does anyone know what the difference of
what things race to the top or I already
raised to power 5 or 6 or 7 we're kind
of you know out there that kind of right
so I want to look at this result like if
I try this question a little bit
differently it'll come to this okay if I
we started today thinking about like
seven threes okay well that would lead
to this right so then I'm what do I do
next
right where or am I going together okay
now I'm going to show you what result we
can use using something sequences okay
that's true you can turn them into
squares
but then for something like this yeah
it's like what are we gonna do okay so
that's a good step it's a good tool but
I want something better okay now just
for a moment
see we said we know a difference of
squares is we know a difference of cubes
is okay let's just conveniently random
elgianne you know people why use
different sets of squares
what's the factorization you get if I
had like W squared minus 1 we would
write w minus 1 and W plus 1 right see
that how these things are the same and
in these things they look kind of
similar don't they if you had to make a
guess just the gifts just throw
something against the wall right what
would you guess the difference of things
to the power 4 ah like this thing seems
to stay
say what would you guess you get on the
other side because you've got like look
at these powers right this is going to
turn out to be cubes so that's why
you've got W to the one there W squared
this they combine to get the W cubed so
down here I mixed with me the first term
should be W cubed and then W Square and
then W and then one right now
that happens to be a very very good
guess that is exactly what it is you can
extend out if you'd like to prove to
yourself what do you think the next one
is I don't write it I'm not gonna write
one always fine you can stop with the W
minus one
what do you think is gonna happen over
here dummy to the form double cube W
squared W 1 W plus 1 now hold on hold on
hold on in series and sequences you know
what this object is this object is that
what kind of thing what's it called this
is a GP right that's a GP that's a GP
that's a GP
I feel like Hello oh no problem get a
car you get a car that's a GP okay so
GPS right let's just think about this
right I mean I'm gonna go all the way
I'm gonna think about something really
general okay let's think about and help
me let me write this right
consider the GP now I want to go up to
some arbitrary path like like seven for
fifty or a hundred okay so in order to
have eighty power I'm gonna say well
let's just think about this guy boss not
the doctor
if it was a general TV right what would
the last turn be if I had say in terms
in this GP or the last one yeah very
good
okay so you can see in a GP we usually
start off a AR AR squared etc we usually
end up with a AR to the N minus one okay
what's my a in this case one
what's my R in this case tell me it's a
root okay alright now one of the first
things you know
you learn about the GP is what's it add
up to now you guys in fact have a
formula for this from - you know what is
the formula let's just write it in its
normal quoted form out over here it
starts with that a what's on the top
okay and of course if we choose we can
write it in Reverse for because
sometimes that's what you sort to us
depending on what by the way why would
you use one person depending on the
value of R is just to avoid a yeah
okay now have a look what would that be
I mean you're a talking about a was it's
your eternal of the collaboration it was
its and then there are how many times
yes W minus one do you see it yet do you
see it all I need to do is multiply both
sides by W minus one right these really
is one plus all the way up and oh look
that numerator there is the difference
of squares cubes for most five sixes
whatever on earth
do you like okay so if I were to
factorizes what would I do I just say
that's cool I know this result from
series of sequences I'm just going to
take out my W minus one and I'm gonna be
left with 13 six five two one
okay so this is all it's actually very
very important this result is very very
important it comes up all the time and
they're not going to tell you you have
to use it it's just gonna sneak in and
you'll have to raise your eyebrow and
say what am I supposed to do with that
heads up that's what you do okay